the philosophy in our collection has
always been that the specimens are here
to be used so every animal will
eventually find a purpose here I'm Ellen
resset our McCarter collection manager
in the amphibian and reptile collection
at Field Museum we are going to be
unboxing the Komodo dragons today a
Komodo dragon is the world's largest
lizard it's not the world's longest
lizard but the Komodo is the largest our
Komodo dragons are kept in this
specially custom-made stainless steel
tank which is over a hundred gallons in
a komodo dragon about this size would
weigh about or maybe about 125 pounds
his organs were removed when he was
necropsy at the zoo so he's a little bit
lighter but he's still pretty heavy
almost all of our 300,000 specimens in
the collection are in 70% ethanol so
essentially what we do is by Everclear
the same product you can buy at the
liquor store
we purchased it in 55-gallon drums and
being a museum we can apply for a
special permit so we don't have to pay
the liquor tax on it so that saves us a
little money the specimens are here for
scientific research so they're here to
be shared with students and researchers
from all over the world they don't come
out as often as I'd like they were here
probably about 18 years before somebody
conducted the first research project on
them but the animals are here forever I
mean our goal is to keep them for
hundreds of years even though a specimen
may sit here a couple decades all of a
sudden there might be a research
interest in them
you know we can move this we just make
sure that nobody's in an empty aisle
right I almost crushed a guy from
Argentina
[Music]
you